und zwar zerstört diese bombe alles und
auch bedrock da unten
herzlich willkommen heute hier am
dienstag zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft command und zwar ist es ja
wieder habe ich ja gesagt manchmal
dienstag von command kommt er einfach zu
lang wäre für eine normale folge am
freitag hr die ehre geht der kommt dann
halt manchmal so einem command der
einfach den dänen rahmen der folge
sprengen würde die ihr am freitag immer
kommt und da habe ich heute einen
command für euch von minecraft werde es
gedacht der macht einfach das echte und
fast wenn ich auf dem tisch lagen gleich
besteht hier die nachbarin mal wenn ich
auf den tischler gewackelt ich die ganze
facebook
warum finde ich dass gerade so
faszinierend der command ist der special
forces command wie schon gesagt von
minecraft ich hole mir erstmal mit
player command ich muss nicht groß da
kann hier auch ein schreiben ich schätze
mal klein einfach command block und dann
noch eben schon einen schalter dann
haben wir hier schon mal das grobe setup
und dafür gehe ich diesen command eines
vogels wieder ganz kurz und wenn ich
jetzt drücke wird eine maschine
erschaffen diese maschine generiert sich
jetzt hier und wir sehen wieder vorne
die typischen minecraft knöpfe einmal um
die items zu kriegen und um die
komplette maschine zu zerstören
wir sehen wieder hier links in minecraft
findet ihr auch in der beschreibung des
machine is fully sm gold also wir können
jetzt hier draufklicken habe die ganze
sache und wir können hier mal einfach
jetzt sind auch meine alterswerk seinem
schädigen die scheiße generiert sich und
wir holen uns jetzt die items und
klicken danach nicht hier unten drauf
sondern wir haben jetzt hier die items
und dann werde ich euch jetzt einfach
mal zeigen was diese einzelnen bomben
können und zwar haben wir erstmal die
flames die ich gerade in der hand haben
die eisbombe rising big bob wares beim
portal bomb und underground nuke und
einmal einig leiter damit kann man nicht
eine bombe aus weiterer entfernung das
ist sie vollständig außen also ich bin
nichts verändert den penis so ein
bisschen was ist das für eine welt
wieder sein penis sydney das ist sogar
ganz cool mit zum kleinen ist egal
jedenfalls kann man die bomben dann
entweder ich zeig euch jetzt mal
beispiel der flame braucht entweder kann
ich die bombe einfach hier so anzünden
dann seht ihr schon okay was passiert da
und alles ist voll mit lava und shit das
kann ich einmal so machen oder ich setze
die bombe einfach hin und
liege hoch und schießt quasi einen fall
da drauf dann dauert das ganze mich ein
bisschen länger ihr seht schon die löst
sich nämlich genau jetzt erst aus jetzt
fängt das ganze ding da es an zu brennen
jeden moment seht ihr das ist jetzt auch
losgeht endlich und jetzt fliegt nämlich
das ganze ding der normalen luft also
quasi das sonne verzögertes auslösen der
bombelmann kann dann natürlich auch den
effekt noch erhöhen mit den ganzen
bomben wenn man dann quasi sag ich mal
drei untereinander nebeneinander stellt
die find ich jetzt mal alle drei an
dann seht ihr schon dann ist der effekt
natürlich dementsprechend noch krasser
also damit als herunterschauen ihr seht
schon bam bam bam bam bam haben wir
natürlich viel mehr was ihr voll mit
lava und flammen aber das war jetzt
erstmal die flame bombe und wir schauen
uns jetzt die eisbombe an die setzt sich
einfach mal hierhin und zündet ihr jetzt
einfach mal hier mit an mit dem
feuerzeug ganz easy ihr seht schon wenn
ich in der nähe bin bekomme ich
langsamkeit auf ein paar sekunden und
jetzt halt ausgelöst und über alles und
so finde ich extrem cool gemacht also
sieht mega es einfach diese bombe oder
und sie löst halt einfach aus dass der
spieler der umgebung steht quasi
langsamkeit bekommt und überall halt
zwei eisblöcke hin gescheppert werden
dann haben wir die pulver rising bomb
wenn ich da mal drauf clique seht ihr
schon die hat so schwartze partikel und
zwar zerstört diese bombe alles und auch
bedrock da unten ihr seht schon hier ist
ein riesiger krater erschaffen worden
und wir sehen die runden
hier kann ich einfach durch fliegen und
zwar ist es wirklich somit die einzige
bombe in dem spiel überhaupt die
wirklich pedro kaputt machen kann also
die zerstört alles bis nach unten weg
inklusive bedrock ist schon mega krass
die kann ich natürlich auch mehrere
zusammensetzen und kriege ich halt schon
riesig riesigen krater setzt sich jetzt
mal eben noch eine flame bomb und noch
ein nebeneinander damit dem ansehen das
ganze aussehen kann wenn ich quasi alle
nacheinander anzünde so jetzt sind ja
alle drei mal angezündet
und jetzt geht's richtig ab freunde
friedrich abgeben so dass man jetzt
explodiert hier wo sind die eisblöcke so
die sind da überall in die saiten
geflogen deswegen habe ich die friedlich
gesehen ja ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal
die big four und zwar die big band ist
einfach nur wie der name schon sagt eine
riesige bombe einfach die wird richtig
ordentlich fast kaputt machen zu nicht
einfach mal an und ihr seht schon u
was ist laut ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
sieht schon überall hier sind so ein
paar krater entstanden natürlich nicht
so trasse pulver aber das sagt der name
auch einfach schon cool bereits so ich
mache alles zu pulver nach dem motto
dann auch eine sehr coole bombe ist die
virus bord und zwar wenn ich diese
anzünde empfiehlt man einerseits wenn
ich in der umgebung bin vergiftet und es
wird so komisches ding sher schaffen
vergiftung und übelkeit und es wird so
virus dinge erschaffen so eine virus
struktur
das sieht gut aus ist wenn das bakterien
oder so und auch da wenn ich ganz ganz
viele zusammen setzt also wenn ich
beispielsweise immer noch ein paar mehr
hinsetzen nochmal so drei stück und die
hier anzünde seht ihr auch schon ob es
nämlich so viele der auch schon ich
bekomme wieder übelkeit und diese
strukturen bauen sich auch immer weiter
nach oben und so weiter und wo etwas
feste in wietze gerade für defekte und
dann erschaffen sich halt hier so
riesige wieder strukturen dass ich schon
die gehen ganz weit nach oben
das sieht echt krass aus mit dem shader
so nah dass die bomben so wow das ist
richtig cool aus oder um das sieht wenn
das so den himmel geht er das sieht
richtig gefährlich ich fühle mich
richtig ängstlich guck mal ich guck dir
so lange dann ist da oben einfach so ein
riesiges ding was da oben so mit dem
schatten im himmel geht er das sieht
richtig crazy aus also na ja die nächste
bombe ist die pforte bonn
da könnt ihr mal sehen wenn ich da drauf
clique und das ganze ding jetzt quasi in
die luft fliegt schon da kommen diese
diese portal ähnlichen sachen hin und
zwar werden bei der portierung sachen
von irgendwie von der umgebung nach oben
geholt sage ich mal
das ist ganz cool wenn man jetzt
beispielsweise einer stadt ist oder so
und dann werden halt so ganze häuser in
wiso nach oben geholt oder so
häuserkomplex oder irgend sowas also das
hole quasi die sachen aus dem untergrund
und zieht die nach oben und die letzte
bombe ist die underground nuke die setzt
jetzt beispielsweise einfach mal hier
hin weil da sieht man das denke ich ganz
gut was damit passiert also setzt jetzt
mal hier rein ja okay jetzt wird man
wahrscheinlich schon was sehen weil das
ganze jetzt erstmal ganz eben kurz und
jetzt sieht man schon also das ganze
passiert halt meistens wirklich im
untergrund dass sie zu krass aus doch
man muss sich bei dem screenshot machen
gesagt bleib dabei wie ich eine mail
kreiere so so dass howie do it simple
just make the picture of what you have
also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise meine
untergrund bombe einfach hierhin seither
kann man es ganz cool zeigen dann sieht
man davon erstmal recht wenig also ihr
seht jetzt bamm bamm bamm dieses ding
explodiert und gut was ist jetzt hier
passiert
na ja nicht so viel eigentlich also hier
sieht man ja nicht so viel allerdings
wenn ich ein gamer 3g und einfach mal
hier durch fliegende schon das hier ist
das wirklich etwas passiert ist also so
in alle möglichen richtungen hier ist
überall noch alles mögliche zerstört
werden also alles möglich im untergrund
dass da hinten weil das was im oberhalb
der der dings war aber das hier ist
alles quasi so im untergrund dass sie
teils schon mega krass aus was diese
bombe hat quasi auslöst was man
allerdings von oben gar nicht so
wahrnehmen kann erstmal drei freunde
wenn ich ihr überfliege ist es einfach
völlig am ruckeln also es läuft halt
immer noch so dass nicht noch mal zocken
kann aber es ist halt trotzdem schon
krass am buckel vorsieht dass gerade
gefährlich aus mit der sonne und diesem
ding da aber ich würde einfach sagen
freunde das war es heute ein konzert das
war es heute hier für diese folge der
minecraft command also eine ganz ganz
kurze folge wie alt ich gesagt habe dass
ich wenn ich kurze commands ab oder so
witzig wie wenig der durch den baum
durch geflogen wie ich halt schon gesagt
habe wenn ich irgendein kurz und command
habt ihr allerdings auch ein bisschen
umfangreichere sachen hinzufügt dann
kommt das ganze mal am dienstag das habe
ich heute getan des videos trotzdem noch
ein bisschen länger geworden weil es
halt so viele items hinzufügt in
minecraft in der beschreibung verlinkt
da könnt ihr euch das ganze nochmal
anschauen wie das ganze noch mal erklärt
wurde und so und dann würde ich sagen
sehen wir uns entweder in der commands
folge am freitag wieder oder in
irgendwelchen anderen videos oder halt
bei dem video days wenn ihr da seid also
ich werde ja die tage freitag und
samstag und sonntag und donnerstag komme
ich in berlin an und plane im flieger
werde ich halt immer da sein da kann man
mich da sehen treffen und so weiter und
so fort aber dazu werde ich denke ich
morgen oder übermorgen noch mal ein
video machen
ja wenn solch gefahr da würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen und wir sehen
uns dann mal wieder tschüss